deuxième jour du procès en appel de jean
pierre murat accusé du meurtre de
christelle marie au creusot il ya 30 ans
dans une perte du quartier de la
charmille était évoquée aujourd'hui 30
ans d'enquêté deux procédures avec de
nombreux manquements pauline ringenbach
christophe gaillard je ne sais pas je ne
m'en souviens plus je ne sais plus
des phrases répété à de nombreuses
reprises aujourd'hui devant la cour
d'assises de côte-d'or lorsqu'il faut
revenir 30 ans en arrière
des souvenirs se mélangent les
déclarations ont beaucoup évolué avec le
temps on constate aussi que pour la
plupart et bien c'est confus puisque
effectivement le temps pacs la plupart
des témoins ne se souvient plus de ce
qu'il a dit il n'a plu n'a plus aucun
souvenir donc bah quand on peut
reprocher à monsieur murat de ne pas se
souvenir je crois que la réciprocité est
également présente pour les témoins à la
barre le premier directeur dont kate a
lui même eu du mal à se souvenir
alors que cette affaire qu'il n'a jamais
pu résoudre à l'époque a marqué la fin
de sa carrière
c'est toujours difficile de arriver à un
constat d'échec par rapport à un crime
de cette de cette sorte une gamine de 16
ans et sa marque c
moi je sais que j'avais une fille de cet
âge là qui reste un jeu est bon qu'ils
auraient pu auraient dû à la crise elle
sa marque
on ne peut pas rentrer chez soi et puis
10 rebonds s'est terminée au delà des
défaillances de mémoire des défaillances
dans l'enquêté dans les procédures ont
été dénoncés la plus importante
la destruction des scellés après un
non-lieu prononcé dans les années 90
plus aucune pièce à conviction malgré
l'évolution des techniques scientifiques
plus de preuves matérielles possibles
dans ce dossier des preuves elles sont
là on va pas condamner un homme sans
preuve et ça serait terrible
on condamne un homme avec des preuves
pas avec ce qu'on appelle la preuve
rennes qui serait l'adn mais encore une
fois pendant des siècles et avec un
justicier qui offrait des garanties en
tout cas on a condamné des hommes et des
femmes sur la base d'un indice peut être
même beaucoup moins ténu ou de preuve
beaucoup plus de ténue que celle qu'on a
retenu contre jean pierre mourocq des
aveux lors d'une soirée entre amis des
carnets nuit sur cette affaire des
années passées à dénoncer ses camarades
pour le meurtre de christelle jean
pierre murat clame aujourd'hui son
innocence mais de nombreux témoignages
tous jouent en sa défaveur
pauline ringenbach vous êtes en direct
de la cour d'appel de dijon c'était
moins que vous évoquez seront entendus
dès lundi oui arnaud une dizaine de
témoins sera entendu à partir de lundi
notamment l'un de ses amis qui étaient
présents lors de cette fameuse soirée au
cours de laquelle à l'époque jean pierre
murat or est avoué le meurtre de
christelle mairi y ait des aveux qu'il
dément totalement aujourd'hui alors ce
sera sûrement l'un des moments clés de
ce procès car depuis deux jours l'accusé
est déjà très agacé il demande demande
même à prendre la parole il demande à
réagir dès qu'une déclaration ne lui que
l'état jean pierre murat nous montrent
un tout autre visage que celui qui nous
a laissé entrevoir l'an dernier lors de
son premier procès il prend beaucoup
plus la parole ce qui ne plaît pas du
tout à son avocate qui lui a d'ailleurs
conseillé de rester beaucoup plus
mesurée à l'avenir face à la cour pour
leur l'audience n'est toujours pas levée
elle se déroule toujours
derrière moi un dernière enquêteurs
celui qui a conclu cette affaire en
suspectant jean pierre murat est en
train de terminer sa démonstration face
aux jurés
la présidente lèvera ensuite audiences
et les débats reprendront lundi à partir
de 9h merci pauline compte-rendu
retrouve également sur notre site
internet